[Music]
awesome good morning everyone my name is
Archer I'm a product manager on Android
system UI I'm Maddie I'm an engineer on
Android system UI and I'm Jason I'm an
engineer on Android system UI and we're
here to talk to you about Android slices
and how you can use them to build
interactive results for a Google search
so before we get into the details I
wanted to start by answering the
question of what slices are and at a
high level slices are androids new
approach for remote content there's a
couple of important aspects to this the
first is that slices are templated what
we mean by this is that we're gonna
provide you with a flexible and rich
mode of expressing your app that's also
predictable and dependable so that they
can be presented by a wide variety of
surfaces slices are also interactive
these templates have a variety of
components to enable anything from rich
content previews to in-line task
completion and also slices are updatable
we're going to be able to iterate much
more quickly than the traditional
platform releases to enable new places
for these slices to appear and new types
of slices for you to express your app
most importantly slices are backwards
compatible all the way back to Android
KitKat which means that as they launch
they're going to be available for 95% of
Android devices so let's dig into some
of these a little bit a little bit more
detail when we say slices are templated
we mean that we're providing you with
the rich layout and content system to
enable a wide variety of app use cases
these templates are not plug-and-play
they're flexible in an instant in that
you define a wide variety of elements
and define them in a priority order so
that to enable a rich variety of ways to
express your app anything from a weather
forecast to a reservation music playlist
to home automation and Maddie is going
to go into a lot more details on how you
construct these slices are also
interactive they're not just static data
they can house a variety of components
anything from real-time data fetch
directly from the apk on a user's device
for example
for saying the latest prices for
ride-sharing as well as rich controls
like actions toggles sliders and
scrolling content so that users can
complete the task in line right where
the slice is being presented slices are
bundled with jetpack that means that we
can more frequently expand and iterate
slices that means we can add more
presenting surfaces to expand your apps
reach more templates to represent your
apps use cases and more controls and
components to make those slices more
engaging and more powerful for users
here's an example of a potential new
messaging template that we're exploring
for the future so all this sounds pretty
great but the really important question
is where a slice is going to be
available for users where are we
launching this year slices are launching
in search where we're gonna use slices
to enhance app predictions as the user
is searching there are going to be two
main use cases in terms of how slices
will appear the first is for app names
so as a user is searching for the name
of your app will be able to surface what
you may call a canonical slice for your
app to help accelerate some sort of task
but will also support general term
searches so that users are able to
search for an app deep link or a
specific feature and of course because
slices are backwards compatible when
they start appearing in search you'll be
able to reach all hundreds of millions
of users that are available on Google
search today this is really important
because with slices you're going to be
enabled you're gonna be able to enable a
wide variety of really great use cases
for folks on search for example here a
couple of three buckets that we are
likely to share to get your juices
flowing the first is a navigation use
case this isn't a sense that the user is
searching for something that they
already know they want to get to for
example the user knows that they already
want to get a ride home well with slices
you can use real-time data to provide
additional context for that decision so
that they know the price and time to
their destination and they can just
start thinking about booking the ride
right from the search results they also
enable inline task completion you might
be able to use those interactive
controls I was referring to earlier so
that apps like settings can enable users
to quickly search for a setting and
toggle it inline
and finally you can use slices to enable
recall and discover use cases users
might be searching for things that they
didn't even realize is available in your
app but because it's installed in their
device and that you can surface slices
for it you might serendipitously surface
that content for them to explore but
this is only just the beginning our goal
with slices is to enable one reusable
API to generalize world content and
Android and different things that we're
exploring is trying to make slices more
tightly integrated into the system as
well as more Google platforms I'm going
to hand it off to Jason to talk a little
bit more about slices architecture
thanks arctor well in a minute Maddie's
gonna walk you through actually building
your first slices but before that I want
to give you a little bit of an idea of
how slices work and what they how they
look under the hood so the slice is what
a slice actually is in terms of you know
implementation is its structured data
and that structured data contains other
slices content and presentational hints
and so one thing to note this is not
actually code on the screen I know it
looks kind of like a DSL but this is
really a string representation of what
you would construct once you're actually
done building a slice on there a few
things that we extract out of this
information the structure that it has
determines to the template and like what
we're seeing like this example of a
horizontal weather slice it also
contains
the content itself icons text pending
intents for interactivity and the other
thing to note is that this contains all
of the data for the slice no matter the
format maddie is going to talk you
through all of the format's that we have
for slices right now and how we may add
more in the future to but a single slice
that you return in your app will
actually hold all of the formats and so
on the right we have a shortcut version
of that same slice and that is using the
exact same data to present in a
different format all right so how do you
how to apps actually get ahold of slices
from your app so slices sit on top of
content providers slice provider extends
a content provider don't worry we try to
hide as much of the content provider as
possible for you but there are a few
really nice things that come out of this
is that they're based on top of content
you are eyes
which means you can have a wide variety
of slices hosted from your app and when
an app wants to show your slice you'll
get a callback to unbind slice and
you'll get a URI and you'll get to
decide what content you want to connect
to that URI and return it in that slice
that I just showed you but then there
they're interactive so you need to
actually be able to update that and the
way that works is through a notify
change you send a standard content
provider notify change on your slice URI
and whoever is presenting your slice
will know that it's time to update and
they'll give you another callback and
you can return different data that is
you know dynamic and changes in response
to whatever has happened all right now
I'm gonna hand it over to Maddy who's
gonna walk you through building your
first slice thanks Jason for that
architectural overview I'm going to walk
you through an app creating this Wi-Fi
slice today so we're going to build a
slice provider that provides this Wi-Fi
space that has this toggle and tapping
the toggle will turn Wi-Fi on and off
and then the connected state will change
based on the Wi-Fi state so the first
thing you've got to do is define a slice
provider in your Android manifest as
Jason mentioned slices are built on top
of content providers - similar to a kind
of provider you got a define a cure this
lets the operating system be able to
find your slices then you have to
implement your site's provider and a
slice provider this links provider
handles multiple slices carrots so we
have a Wi-Fi slice an alarm slice and a
nightlight slice so what will happen
when when something is trying to display
your slice you might type in Wi-Fi into
Google search and it's going to do some
ranking stuff but Jason will go into
some details later and it'll map that
search term to a Content URI and in our
case that content URI will be this Wi-Fi
path based on that we're gonna build a
Wi-Fi slice so we'll jump into this
method and slices start with list
builders so list builder accepts
different kinds of rows of content this
Wi-Fi slice is fairly
well it's a single row and so we first
start with our list builder we build a
row builder based off of it we add the
Wi-Fi title and then we kind of do this
weird thing where we check if Wi-Fi
state is loaded maybe it takes some time
for us to determine whether Wi-Fi is
connected or not and we need to do that
in the background in the meantime we're
still going to return a slice with the
content we intend to display but we kind
of note that this content is loading so
the toggle we don't know the state and
the connected text we don't know whether
we're connected or not so these two
pieces we need to indicate they're
thought they're going to be loaded we do
that just by passing DeLand Abilene on
the Builder methods we then add that row
to the list builder and we build the
slice so meanwhile our Wi-Fi state has
been loading maybe when this is done it
we get a callback to on Wi-Fi state
loaded we flip our flag and now we need
to let the UI know to update so our
Wi-Fi slice is being displayed somewhere
and it is our sad little loading state
with just the Wi-Fi text so we need to
let it know to update to get that
subtitle string and the toggle action
and we do that with the content resolver
and notify change on the full content
URI for that slice so you'll get a call
to you on by and slice again it'll be
the same Wi-Fi URI and you'll walk into
your build Wi-Fi slice method and this
time our Wi-Fi stays loaded so we can
check whether we're connected or not it
set that subtitle text and create our
toggle action so this get Wi-Fi toggle
action is going to create a slice action
this is how we represent actions and
slices so the slice action basically
wraps the pending intent and then takes
some extra information to represent the
action in our case we want to respond to
someone tapping on the toggle so we need
to have a broadcast receiver to receive
that pending intent and
do some stuff to update Wi-Fi state so
we build our slice action with that
intent and a label and describing the
action and then a boolean value
representing whether this toggle is on
or off so in our case the Wi-Fi state so
when you tap on that Tago that pending
intent gets sent your but you'll define
this bar you'll define a broadcast
receiver for your app to handle this
intent in our case we need Wi-Fi manager
to update Wi-Fi State something neat
that slices does four toggles is so if
the Wi-Fi was on I tap on that toggle
that pending intent gets sent will
attach the resulting state of the toggle
this extra toggle state to that intent
so that you can retrieve it and know
what the new state of the toggle is
we'll use that just update the Wi-Fi and
then we're going to notify our content
URI so that any slices any Wi-Fi slices
being displayed no to update because
Wi-Fi and state has changed so how do
you test these and right now we've got
this great tool sliced viewer and it
allows you to input your content URIs
for your slices and then you can preview
your slice it'll display the slices in
different modes so as Jason mentioned we
had that shortcut and then larger
templates so this tool will allow you to
exercise those different modes that
slice the support and the getting
started is great getting started guide
is great I'd highly recommend it so
that's kind of the summary of creating a
slice from an app you have your slice
provider in your manifest you implement
it you map your content you are eyes to
the different slices that your app
supports and then you build them and
handle any events and of course test ok
templates slices has a really great
templating system we think it's pretty
flexible and we hope that we'll be able
to support many of your app use cases
and this is an overview of the different
row types we support so as I mentioned
everything starts with a list builder
and list builder you attach different
rows to it so this kind of the slide
sort of shows the different rows that we
support and you see text toggles sliders
progress bars different kinds of grid
layouts and these are all kind of
flexible so nothing is enforcing
requirements of content so you can kind
of pick and choose how you use these so
as mentioned you add these to list
builder and and you can kind of see in
these layouts how you can express your
app uniquely with the system so Wi-Fi
slice here is composed of just different
types of rows supports the toggle it can
do a list of Wi-Fi networks our
reservation slice for your upcoming trip
in Seattle it gives you the important
information gives you a preview of your
rental and then check-in checkout
locations using a big picture and then a
grid layout with two cells and then our
music slice it's interactive you can
favorite things you can control your
music from it it's scrollable so I hope
that you can see how your app use cases
could be represented in our template
system so multiple formats as Jason
mentioned and you provide a slice with
all of your all of the data we need to
present in these different formats we
want slices to be able to move across
the operating system in different spaces
and they might need to shift their form
based on that so we're supporting a
shortcut form which is just a small
tappable icon a small slice which is the
first row of your slice generally and
then a large slice which is all of the
content so when you're building your
slice keep out in mind make sure you
test the different modes so that the
slice displays how you expect it to in
these formats things presenting slices
can also customize them so they've got
some flexibility with increasing font
size changing the font style and maybe
overriding any colors that you set
because we want slices to sort of feel
at home
in the surface that they're being
presented in so I'm going to walk you
through an example to build this Home
Slice which allows you to control your
temperature and see the many video
cameras that you might have in your home
so again starts with a list builder here
we're defining to slice actions for
turning the temperature up and turning
the temperature down these just take a
pending intent icon compat and then a
label we create our row we set our title
and subtitle add the two actions add the
road to the list and then we've got that
top part of the slice so we'll do the
second part now the camera snapshots
maybe we'll get our data for this this
is a grid row so we'll build define a
grid row builder and then for each of
the data elements we're displaying in
these cells we'll add a cell to the grid
builder and the cell will take an image
title text and text and these are
displayed in the order that you add them
to the cell builder so if you want to
mix them up they don't need to be image
text text it could be text image text
and so again it's flexible add that grid
Road for the list and then you've built
your slice and Jason is going to take it
away to describe how you can get these
slices appearing a Google search thanks
Maddy all right so Lake Archer said
we've got two cases that we're talking
about for Google search these are both
showing up in predictions so you know
you can tap on the search bar type a few
characters and the user will be
interacting with your app basically at
that point one thing to note this is
only for apps installed on your device
we aren't currently doing anything with
instant apps or stuff from the cloud and
these next few slides are really just a
preview we're going to be launching all
sorts of documentation when we
officially ship this later this summer
all right so let's talk through how you
do this for an app name there are two
things you really need to do in this
case you need to link of specific slice
to your main activity of your app that's
the activity that shows up in launcher
and the activity that the with the name
that users will search for and you need
to grant some permissions
so linking the activity is actually
really really simple you just add one
piece of metadata into your manifest and
that metadata points at any slice URI
you want within your app and that's the
URI that you can expect to get bound
when the users type in the name of your
app you also need to grant these
permissions explicitly to search and
Play services so that it has access to
read to your slice and display it
properly we'll talk a bit more about
permissions and in a little bit but
these are basically the lines of code
you need to do for a default slice or an
app slice okay so the the bit more broad
range of general terms this is a little
bit more complicated the another thing
to notice that ranking may vary is that
you know search is going to try to
present whatever content is best for the
user and so you can't always guarantee
that your app is going to be shown but
that can be enhanced with a bit of you
know usage reporting and stuff like that
there are a few things you need to do
here this is based on top of firebase
app indexing which is existing api's you
can go read about them we've got a link
on the next slide and you tie those
firebase app indexing content directly
to a slice and so that will let search
know when it triggers that app indexable
that it should be showing a slice for
that so the way you do that is when you
are pushing your app indexable there is
some metadata you can tag there's new
api's on app indexing that will be
launched with this which will let you
specify your slice URI another piece of
this is that there's a little bit of
content validation so when you're doing
app indexing you need to specify a
content URL and that content URL needs
to map to the same slice that you're
specifying with your app it's just a
linking sort of a system to verify that
you've got the right content showing and
so the way that works is there are two
things you need to do one is you need to
add an intent filter to your provider
these have been supported but are rarely
used in android for some time these look
very similar to app linking if you're
familiar with verified app linking or
app linking this will look pretty
similar to you this intent filter is an
example it's looking for anything on
HTTP colon example.com slash any
thing you can also do if you don't have
a plinking set up for your app you can
do your own URL schemes like in the
settings app in Android we're doing
settings colon slash slash whatever for
our deep links and that's our URL scheme
the other thing you do is once you've
added an intent filter for your for your
provider you can expect that you're
going to get calls to on map intent to
URI this lets your apps say I've got
some intent incoming intent data and
intents are kind of squishy
you know intents aren't as defined as a
URI and this gives you the moment to say
like here I'm going to take this intent
and I'm going to resolve it to an exact
URI and this is the slice I want to show
and so you can do whatever you want
within this function to it to determine
your path in this case it's just kind of
like taking the data off from the intent
and pushing it over to Authority with
the which is a slice provider but you
can you can add your own logic of your
own kind and that's how you add those
all right so that's kind of a whirlwind
tour I know we'll be launching more docs
with that when we when we officially
launch research now hopefully your
slices are holding all sorts of really
great content and you don't want to
expose that content to the world so you
probably really care about how the
permissions work here so there are three
ways that an app can get ahold of
permissions for your slice the first is
you get fine-grained permission controls
these are very similar to URI
permissions except we designed them to
scale up because we expect people to
have a lot of slices over time these
happen automatically for you if you're
using the firebase app indexing API as
we just told you about will do those
permission grants for you you notice and
the default app slice you didn't have
that firebase app indexing which is why
you had to grant the permission to
yourself in the second case that is
different about these from URI
permissions is that the user can grant
permission when when an app doesn't have
permission to show your slices the
system will return what we call a
permission slice it looks something like
this on the right or it says like hey
this app's trying to show slices from
someone else and the user can actually
explicitly grant and the third case of
where apps can get slice permissions is
that on P plus we're Auto granting
permission to launcher in the assistant
to really be able to do those two
seamless kinds of slice integrations in
the future and so if the user clicks on
that permission slice that I mentioned
they're gonna see a dialogue and they
can choose you know to either to grant
permissions or not to grant permissions
try to give them some transparency as to
what's going on and how they're exposing
data from your app because so so how
does this work for you the way it works
for you is that you should extend slice
provider because you're gonna need to
for everything and slice provider is
going to handle all of this permission
checking for you
it's going to do all that please don't
add Android : permission to your
providers as you're used to in your
manifest that's going to break
everything and also if you have really
really sensitive data if you're
something like a banking app and you
feel like oh no the you know I could
users could really really shoot
themselves in the foot here you can
override on create permission request
and that will let you disable disable
the user grant and like redirect them to
some other dialog you can you can have
your own sort of flow there to ensure
privacy all right and I'm gonna pass it
back to Archer to wrap things up awesome
so that was a lot of information if
you're interested in learning more
please go to this short link gqo slash
slices in here is everything related to
our getting started guide as well as
links to use and download the slices
viewer building your first slice and all
the details that you need to know about
creating all the rich templates that
maddie talked about will also be
available today and tomorrow at office
hours that'll be posted on our thank you
slides as well as the Android sandbox if
you have any direct questions we also
want to hear from you so please go to
this google.com slash IO /schedule link
to provide feedback on this session but
thank you all again so much for coming
in the wee hours of the morning and
hearing us talk about slices as well
again you can follow these two follow-up
actions to learn more we also have a bit
of time for questions right now if
anyone has anything burning that they
want to ask
[Music]